hi I'm Erik Bosse and Toy Story 4
released a trailer with a brief look at
footage from the new movie yes another
adventure for these toys because toys
don't really have a life cycle they just
live on and on and watch every human
they ever care about right you know what
enough dark interpretations that Pixar
movies they're meant to just be fun and
not not too deeply about but we can
still pick apart this limited footage
for all the interesting details that you
might have missed and clues about what
this movie might be about spoiler
watergate's they reveal too much and
ruin your life and let's get started wow
this place is amazing
why the buns gonna meet us here he must
be held up somewhere hey up here Astro
Boy if you think you can take our top
prize spot your room dead wrong okay so
this fourth chapter of the Toy Story
saga introduced to us with the familiar
voice there's really Newman at least
part of it will take place at a carnival
how did Woody and Buzz end up here well
according to a synopsis released for
this movie Bonnie the girl and II left
the toys with and Toy Story 3 we'll take
these toys on a road trip
leading to an unexpected detour this
will reconnect him with long-lost friend
Bo Peep voice by Annie Potts if remember
Bo Peep didn't appear in Toy Story 3 she
was a bit of a loose end mentioned as a
toy whom Andy gave away over the years
to another owner
we've lost friends along the way Bo Peep
yeah even even Bo all good toys who've
gone on to new owners Jase I thought we
were keeping things light
woody basically suggested Bo Peep moved
to a nice farm and you know what that
means
furnace but it turns out Bo Peep is fine
she's got a new outfit she was made of
porcelain she and her sheep were part of
a lamp set I think but her dress
appeared to be removable cloth and now
she rocks this cape the synopsis says
that Bo Peep spent years of life on her
own resulting in an adventurous spirit
and like all adventurous nomads Bo peeps
a carny it sounds like the core theme
attic question of this movie will be a
toys purpose woody is always seen a toys
function is taking care of a child
bringing them joy as a plaything in his
mind toys must be linked with a human to
have value these are lessons woody will
apparently try to impart on the new
character in this movie porky the spork
voiced by Tony Hale for he is going
through a sort of exit
crisis he identifies this trash rubbish
said Bonnie crafted together as an art
project then she played with porky she
named him she gave him a soul and
wreaked in the hell out but it sounds
like Woody's worldview will be
challenged by reuniting with Bo Peep now
a toy without a human free and unlike
the mindless unclaimed alien toys a
pizza planet or the depressed abandoned
toys that what he's meant like lots o
stinky Pete or Jesse when he first met
her maybe Bo Peep is loving her
independence like she could have found a
purpose without a human to be
responsible for and this would be a
whole new concept for woody freedom but
freedom free from abandonment perhaps in
Toy Story 4 woody will fear that Bonnie
left him behind on a road trip like
Daisy did with lots oh and that could
risk turning woody into another
villainous Lotso but Bo Peep will show
woody that Moss toys don't have to feel
abandoned they can live whatever life
they want we'll have to see how this
would affect woody and Buzz's
relationship because buzz as a Space
Ranger is more of a natural adventurer
Tim Allen actually teased in an
interview about how this movie would end
I'll get to that in a second but first
thanks to our sponsor mass drop so what
I do these in-depth breakdowns of
trailers I really need a good set of
headphones to listen to stuff closely
I'm sure you're pretty dependent on good
headphones - whenever you're you know
working gaming watching stuff on YouTube
or muting the screening kids on long
flights no joke for years I was stuck
using some dinky ones but mass drop just
sent me there HD 58 X headset and I've
been testing it out for a few days now I
used it to make this video actually or
editors I've actually been trying them
out too as they've been working on it
hey guys I freaking love these things
and they're super company they have an
open back design so my ears don't sweat
even after wearing them for like two or
three hours like I did today and there's
padding that make them fit all snuggly
on my big old dumb head more importantly
the audio quality is awesome so like I
can hear subtle variations with sound
effects and dialogue as I'm looking for
clues and the way these trailers have
been edited because you know how
sometimes they like to dub over audio
from one scene on a trailer onto another
scene kind of feel like an Lennon
surveillance on these toys so if you're
in the market to upgrade your headphones
I can personally recommend the HD 58 X
as a high quality option and I'm not
alone the HD 58 X is over twenty
thousand purchases on mass drop with a
five star rating
so get on this just go to dr
PS / new rockstars - HD 58 X or click on
the link in the description below
okay back to Tim Allen's ending tease he
said that he and Tom Hanks recorded the
final two lines of the movie and they
both got choked up saying that it would
be a memorable heart-wrenching moment so
I'm dying to know what these final two
lines are a farewell as buzz leaves on
his next adventure
maybe an emotional admission from woody
reversing his angry you are a toy now
telling buzz you are not a toy so long
partner let's cheer ourselves up with
some fun Pixar Easter eggs hidden among
this carnival imagery there's that
whirly ride on the right to the shape of
a purple octopus that could be a
reference to stretch in Toy Story 3 also
if you look way in the back you can make
out a balloon cart just like the one mr.
Fredricksen worked at and up girls to
see an antique shop on the street behind
the carnival maybe this is actually
where Bo Peep ended up as a rare
porcelain lamp piece I gotta say with
this the amount of detail and photo
realism that Pixar animators are able to
pull off these days heads gotten insane
look at this shady and a texturing on
woody compared to the first Toy Story
look we might begin in a little close to
that whole uncanny valley you know where
animators try to make something look
more more realistic and they start to
deprive things of a soul like as the
carnies zip ties buzz to the prize toy
wall
check it out they put dirt under this
person's fingernails was this necessary
yes as a carnival barker sometimes you
got to get your hands dirty I should
point out that also included among the
prizes are some guitar toys that kind of
look like the guitar some cocoa and some
wizard bananas amazing and a booth next
door there's a plush start with the same
blue and pink color scheme that Sully
has let's move on to the second clip
help me get out of here oh wow
like that cheetah okay so buzz is
meeting two new characters duckie and
bunny voiced by keegan-michael key and
Jordan Peele we met them in that earlier
promo spot but look closely behind buzz
you could see a famous Pixar Easter Egg
that shows up in all these movies the
image of the luxo ball star showing up
on the side of that rocket toy ducky
kicks Buzz in the head saying in the
vacuum of space they cannot hear you
back it's actually a nod to the tagline
of the movie alien buzz snaps the dome
hood over duckies foot calling back his
move that he used on woody during his
fight in the first movie and I know I
was talking about creepy photo realism
and the uncanny valley but there's
actually a small missable animation
error here notice how when ducky first
kicks buzz-buzz his head stretches all
the way to the side passing through his
shoulder like there's no gap in the dome
rim for his head to fit in there there's
plastic there this is physically
impossible space see this is called
clipping and you've probably seen it
before in video games hilariously bad
graphics or sometimes even in final
versions of animated films there's that
shot during let it go and frozen when
Elsa flips her hair back and her braid
passes through her arm but it's not
always an accident like what Elsa you
don't really even notice the clipping
because honestly her hair flip just
looks a lot cooler this way and with
Buzz here it's funnier to see his head
bend all the way to the side kind of
like a cartoon
so despite Pixar's ability to make their
characters super realistic they're still
willing to violate physics to help punch
up their visual gags just I think the
way we want it now there's still more
and more coming out about Toy Story 4
there's actually a postive release that
showed mr. Pricklepants from Toy Story 3
he's gone back although no sign of
Buttercup dolly or Trixie so that's
weird
also if you look closely on bo-peep
shoulder there's this tiny little guy
not sure who he is yet there's also
going to be another new character named
Duke kaboom
he's voiced by Keanu Reeves and he's a
toy from Buzz Lightyear's merchandise
line apparently he was hidden somewhere
in the movie The Incredibles too but I
want to know from you guys what do you
think the final two lines of Toy Story
port will be comment down below with
your thoughts follow me on Twitter and
Instagram @ e a vos and subscribe to
this channel and our new podcasts
wherever you listen to podcasts and
because every ending must make you cry
along partners
[Music]